Tom you did the proper British thing you
went to an all-boys school is that right
yes yeah I did yeah be well-behaved
no oddly for spider-man they sent you
back to school oh well it was a joke I
was a joke
they don't obviously understand my
British sarcasm I said wouldn't it be
funny if I went to an American high
school undercover to see what it would
be like to be an American high schooler
and waffle were like that's amazing
let's set it up so six weeks later I've
like with a backpack pencil case books
on my way to the school the Bronx School
of Science arches a school for genius
kids and believe me everyone I am not
know Jesus and yes why I enrolled in a
high school for three days I had like an
accent a fake name a backstory and they
say name Ben Perkins who's my acting
coach from when I was a kid but they
paired me with a kid called Arun and I
was supposed to be his brother or
something like that and Arun is an
Indian kid and when I came in it was
like yeah we're just distant brothers
from you-know-who anyway this is a
science school they can figure things
out
didn't you but then you did did you
confided the people so our sitting next
is very pretty girl in class and you
have to go through an exam process to
get into this school which obviously I
didn't do and she's like hey man what's
your deal how are you here so let me
tell you my secret I'm actually um I'm
actually spider-man she's like dude
you're [__] nuts bro
no seriously I'm spider-man ever see
none of my movies that come out no one
knew about it it was a big secret so I
just looked like some Nutter put three
days and then disappeared
yeah she's laughing now she's
[Music]
you